préparation des sacs de provisions des
cadeaux pour les participants et gérer
les ultimes inscriptions c'est la
dernière ligne droite avant le marathon
de tours les 1000 bénévoles s'active
avant l'arrivée des coureurs
c'est une énorme machine maintenant on
est considéré parmi les dix plus grandes
courses en france l'an passé le marathon
5e français pour la première
édition c'était du jamais vu dans les
annales de déclassement des marathons
français 33e édition des 10 20 km
environ 11000 personnes seront présentes
pour l'événement en famille entre amis
entre collègues amateurs ou coureurs
aguerris
chacun à son rythme se lancera dans la
course c'est un atout majeur économique
pour information l'an passé il n'y avait
plus d'hôtellerie jusqu'à chez nous donc
c'est quand même économiquement
intéressant pour le département pour la
région parce que ça dépasse aujourd'hui
largement les frontières de la région
le marathon touraine loire valley
entamera lui sa deuxième édition
près de deux mille huit cents coureurs
et participeront avec parmi eux des
élites marathonienne venus du monde
entier sur plus de 42 kilomètres le
parcours aura pour départ et arrivée
la ville de tours mais pas seulement
mais le marathon c'est un parcours
exceptionnel dans un environnement
exceptionnel entre la loire à vélo les
bords de loire classée unesco et au semi
marathon et bien la découverte des
jardins de villandry et de son château
dès vendredi les coureurs pourront venir
retirer leurs dossards au village
installé pour l'occasion dans la galerie
marchande de la riche pour les
retardataires les inscriptions seront
encore ouverte
et pour les moins courageux rendez vous
dimanche la salle anatole france dès 9
heures